what's up everyone Jared here a few
months ago we got an email from a fan
named red requesting a video comparing
the portrayal of nihilism in Rick and
Morty and Bojack horseman so we head up
our resident nihilism expert and
sweatiest writer a wisecrack michael
burns to take a stab at it and if you
guys have requests - be sure to
subscribe and hit us up with some ideas
so thanks to red we're gonna give you
guys a crash course in the contemporary
nihilism with legendary lothario Rick
Sanchez and Bojack horseman save it for
YouTube so welcome to this wisecrack
addition on nihilism with Bojack and
rick and as always spoilers ahead many
assume that nihilism simply means
believing in nothing nothing but it
actually refers to a number of
philosophical psychological and ethical
positions and while they all differ
these different flavors of nihilism all
begin from the shared premise that there
is no inherent meaning value or order in
life
there's a solution here you're not
seeing although many an angsty edge lord
might get a kick out of using nihilus
catchphrases to show the world their
heart of darkness you don't speak
because of Friedrich Nietzsche in
reality most of these folks miss out on
the complexity of nihilism rather than a
philosophy best embodied by Tyler Durden
nihilism can be the basis for meaningful
worldviews today we're going to narrow
our focus down to two different branches
of nihilism existential nihilism and
cosmic nihilism also known as cosmic
pessimism to help us navigate the
wonderful world of existential nihilism
we'll be talking about everyone's
favorite functionally alcoholic horse
Bojack horseman and to provide insight
into the cold rationality of cosmic
nihilism we're turning to another
functional alcoholic Rick Sanchez but
don't worry even if you have a healthy
relationship with alcohol you'll still
be able to figure out which nihilism is
right for you
part one existential nihilism
existential nihilism is the nihilism
experienced when we realize that there
is no inherent meaning to our lives and
at its core human existence is just a
precarious dance upon the grave it's up
to us to create meaning in our lives
through our own freedom and decisions we
can have values but we must create and
sustain them and it's this worldview
which fuels Bojack horseman
I'm responsible for my own happiness I
can't even be responsible for my own
breakfast but before we get into the
nihilist undercurrents of Bojack
horseman let's take a look back at the
history of nihilism the term nihilism
was first coined at the end of the 18th
century by German philosopher Friedrich
Jacobi in response to enlightenment
reason which he worried would explain
away the conditions for religion this
rationalist method explained away any
spaces of uncertainty or mystery
rendering everything there was knowable
sound familiar
one of the first philosophers to think
through the implications of nihilism was
Soren Kierkegaard who the New York Times
has referred to as the Danish doctor of
dread although Kierkegaard never used
the word existentialism he's regarded as
one of the fathers of modern
existentialism and while Kierkegaard
wasn't known for the substance abuse
typical were many nihilus he did pour so
much sugar into his coffee that it piled
up above the liquid like an iceberg
warning of adult onset diabetes true
story which is insane and probably more
dangerous than sipping scotch before you
get out of bed Kierkegaard thought that
despair was an essential part of the
human experience which he referred to as
the sickness unto death
this human despair is dialectical which
basically means you're always at odds
with yourself or to put differently I
don't know how to be Diane doesn't get
better and it doesn't get easier I can't
keep lying to myself saying I'm gonna
change I'm poison for example we're
either in despair because we think
nothing is possible it happened again
why do I keep thinking things will make
me happy what is wrong with me or we
despair because we think everything is
possible and can't make a decision what
should I do
maybe break for it drive to Mexico start
a new life there meet a local girl fall
in love talk my way into a line job at a
textile plant gradually work my way up
until I own the place now what am I
talking about I can't run a textile
plant that's way too much responsibility
oh what am I gonna do the walls are
closing in we're in despair about being
who we are
am I just doomed to be the person that I
am look at the person in that book or in
despair because we can't be who we think
we are all this time I assumed there was
more to me than everyone thought but
maybe there isn't this despair is the
root of the melancholy that plagues much
of the human experience to say
melancholy we see in almost all the
characters of Bojack horseman
from Todd's worries about his sexuality
I think I'm a sexual to Princess
Carolyn's anxieties about motherhood
your pregnancy is no longer viable
well how do we make it viable again
mm-hmm except mr. peanut butter he seems
fine and of course Bojack is a character
that seems to have it all successful
acting career beautiful home money and
women yet he can't seem to enjoy any of
it and even when seemingly good things
happen to him he manages to either feel
disappointed you're an Oscar nominee how
do you feel I feel I feel I feel the
same or sabotage his own happiness just
to be clear since this morning
you ate all the muffins yeah I ate them
all in one sitting because I have no
self-control
and I hate myself no matter what
decision he makes he's marked by regret
and no matter how well things work out
Bojack is haunted by an unshakable
despair Kierkegaard describes this
experience in his book either-or if you
marry you will regret it if you do not
marry you will also regret it whether
you marry or you do not marry you will
regret both no matter what Bojack does
whether it's virtuous or selfish the
stench of regret follows look what I do
to the people I'm supposed to care about
I had sex with the one person I've ever
seen you be in love with and for
Kierkegaard this isn't an exception to
the human condition it's the very nature
of the human condition we see Bojack
experiencing this type of self-doubt
during an anxiety attack he has in
season four idiot would you do all Dave
pieces for Kierkegaard anxiety is caused
by the uncertainty that lies beneath
every decision and he considers anxiety
one of the ways that we experience
freedom because were free were
responsible for our own decisions and
the weight that these decisions leads to
anxiety
kirkegaard describes this anxiety as
standing at the edge of an abyss anxiety
may be compared with dizziness he whose
eye happens to look down into the
yawning abyss becomes dizzy
hence anxiety is the dizziness of
freedom and this terrifying freedom
means we can literally do anything
including botch suicide attempts via
yellow convertible for care card the
only way to work through this anxiety in
despair is the
acceptance of the cosmic absurdity of
reality and living one's life by faith
but if you're not keen on using religion
to combat meaninglessness don't worry
Kierkegaard thinks that faith is simply
the courage to attempt a meaningful
existence in the face of a meaningless
world sometimes you need to take
responsibility for your own happiness we
see this at the conclusion of season 4
while nothing drastic has changed Bojack
has accepted the complexity of his
relationship with his mother Oh jack Oh
jack is that you yeah it's me and has
decided to find meaning in his new
little sister hollyhock almost a hundred
years after Kierkegaard collapsed in the
street and died a French philosopher
named jean-paul Sartre picked up the
mantle and developed the first
explicitly existentialist philosophy and
in a move that both Rick and Bo Jack
would love Sartre had many of his
philosophical insights while drinking at
bars in Paris while Bo Jack himself
isn't a fan I stand by my critique of
self drugs Sartre argued that
existentialism is a way to respond to
the meaninglessness of the universe by
creating meaning ourselves so while
there is no ethical value to be found in
the world nor a god to take comfort in
humans can create meaning through our
own lives there may be no cure to
despair and anxiety but at least we can
try to make our lives meaningful however
it's important to remember that while
existential nihilism offers the
possibility of a meaningful life it
guarantees us nothing and it's our
responsibility to constantly create
meanings as Kierkegaard said we must
live forward and understand backwards
closure is a made-up thing by Steven
Spielberg to sell movie tickets it's
like true love and the Munich Olympics
doesn't exist in the real world the only
thing to do now is just to keep living
forward part to cosmic nihilism or
pessimism now that we've seen the ways
in which existential nihilism manages to
offer some meaning in hope let's look at
the less optimistic branch of nihilism
cosmic nihilism cosmic nihilism is a
colder hyper-rational branch of thought
which argues that there is no truth or
meaning to be found in the universe and
even constructed human meanings like
freedom love hope and joy are just myths
we believe in order to cope with the
empty void at the center
our reality even the meanings we create
are at best fables that act as coping
mechanisms cue Morty nobody exists on
purpose nobody belongs anywhere
everybody's gonna die come watch TV for
the cosmic nihilist it's okay to keep
busy while we wait for the coming heat
death of the universe but we're kidding
ourselves if we think we're capable of
creating genuine meaning for the most
part this seems to fit the philosophy of
Rick Sanchez who while admitting nothing
matters still waxes poetic about taking
the universe for a ride when you know
nothing matters the universe is yours
and I've never met a universe that was
into it
the universe is basically an animal and
grazes on the ordinary creates infinite
idiots just to eat them not unlike your
friend Timmy Tommy
yeah hardly matters now sweetie you know
smart people get a chance to climb on
top take reality for a ride but it'll
never stop trying to throw you and
eventually it will there's no other way
off Bojack surgeon of this sentiment is
slightly more optimistic the universe is
a wild beast you can't try to cosmic
nihilism explains Rick's overall
hedonism he's happy to spend his days
partaking in orgies and drinking himself
into a stupor and if Rick believes in
science it seems more likely just a way
to spend his time than some way to
improve the lives of those around him
while existential nihilism might work
for the optimists and hippies any good
edge lord knows that cosmic nihilism
is the only philosophical position for
those brave enough to turn themselves
into a pickle rick and morty goes to
great lengths to establish rick as this
kind of nihilist reducing everything to
science and while not a cosmic nihilist
himself the spiritual forefather of this
position is Prussian moustache of the
Year runner-up 1883 Friedrich Nietzsche
his famous nihilist adage God is dead
has been scrawled in as many Highschool
bathroom walls as the phone number for
your mom this phrase is often
misinterpreted as meaning that God is
dead there is no meaning and everything
sucks
what cosmic nihilism is not a value
judgement about reality or a counter
ethics to religion it's not Rick Sanchez
yelling this or this if God exists it's
in me or this goddess alive we made him
up for money and even Nietzsche himself
wasn't ready for the full-on jump into
the void required for the full
membership into the cosmic nihilus Club
unlike Nietzsche and nihilism cosmic
nihilism takes a more cold and
rationalist approach meanings namely
that there is no inherent value to
existence
Rick and Morty takes this to new heights
not only is the universe cold and
uncaring there's an infinite number of
them nobody nothing you think matters
matters this isn't special realities
including this yes one brand of
contemporary thought eliminative
materialism would bring joy to rigged
space this position championed by the
husband-and-wife tag-team patricia and
paul Churchland argues that many
common-sense attitudes inherited from
modern psychology should be dropped in
favor of more scientific and empirical
notions and in an ironic twist for a
married couple they believe that notions
such as love should be dismissed as folk
psychology when you say that you love
your partner you're just describing a
chemical process occurring in the brain
in response to stimuli or to quote Rick
what people call love is just a chemical
reaction that compels animals to breed
and while Bojack might find meaning in
his lingering love for Diane a good
eliminate abyss like Rick knows that
human emotions are fundamentally bull
can also view Beth season3 Ark in this
light she's torn between Jerry and Rick
on the one side pure sentimental
irrational love for a buffoon and on the
other side with her father the kind of
cold calculation that says it's fine to
replace yourself with an identical clone
and abandon your family while you go on
space adventures I can make a clone of
you a perfect instance of you with all
your memories an exact copy in every way
it'll love and provide for the kids you
could be gone a day a week or the rest
of your life with zero consequences but
if Rick had a favorite contemporary
philosopher there's a good chance it
would be Thomas Metzinger
unlike those who assume that the human
self is a real thing that we all have
Metzinger argues that no such thing has
ever existed instead of having a self
inside us er
that all we are is a jumbled network of
neurons and chemicals the self is just a
useful fantasy we use to make sense of
our experience like a sort of
psychological fairytale so what I'm
saying is that you all as you're sitting
here are systems that simulate and
emulate themselves for themselves as
they're listening to me
and if Metzinger is right we all have to
give up the illusion that humanity has
any real purpose or that we all have
some kind of special unique soul as a
show Rick and Morty frequently
trivializes the self in consciousness as
Rick's creations become sentient and
have existential crises there's this
classic you pass butter welcome to the
club and also this hello this brand of
nihilism can end up sounding
misanthropic a theme we of course
associate with Rick whose primary reason
for spending time with his own grandson
is that his stupidity serves as an
interdimensional cloaking device for his
own genius is with a Morty the genius
waves get canceled out by the morty
waves this rejection of the self makes
cosmic nihilism much less prone to
ethics than its artsy cousin existential
nihilism
in fact the freedom so celebrated by the
existentialist turns out to be just
another illusion for the cosmic vilest
so there isn't anything to ground ethics
the only thing that's certain is
destruction and if there is no value on
which to build an ethical system then
one is free to do whatever they want
whether that means watching TV or
engaging in the intergalactic arms trade
for the sake of hitting your favorite
arcade or turning an entire planet into
monsters killing yourself abandoning
your family and sitting down for a beer
moments later cuz what's the difference
Rick isn't exactly fumbling for meaning
but he knows he probably has a few
inescapable emotions he might as well
just deal with
I don't know Morty maybe I hate myself
maybe I think I deserve to die
and even though Rick surely shares some
ideas with Bojack his cosmic nihilism
makes him a closer philosophical
relative of rust coal philosophical
terms I'm what's called a pessimist we
are things that labor under the illusion
of having a self program with total
assurance that we are each somebody when
in fact everybody's nobody
coincidentally another misanthropic
alcoholic part three steed versus
sanchez so at this point you might be
wondering what's the right nihilism for
me well do you find yourself fighting
off the despair of a shallow and
meaningless world do you continue to
search for purpose and goodness despite
your awareness of this meaninglessness
and then I'll be remembered if I win an
Oscar
I'll be remembered and then what and
then my life will have meaning I don't
know are most of your friends and
associates sentient animals with
important jobs well then you might be an
existential nihilist love and meaning
are possible for you but it'll take some
hard work without guaranteed so pick up
some Kierkegaard Sartre or Simone de
Beauvoir and hit the local Bistro for
some strong cocktails and spirited
conversation on the other hand you doubt
the inherent meaning of human existence
do you feel no ethical obligations to
friends or family is your best friend a
bird person
well then cosmic nihilism might be the
best life philosophy you've been waiting
for if that's the case download season 1
of true detective and search the dark
web for some nootropic drugs to enhance
your rational capacities and maybe set
up a countdown clock on your wall to get
ready for the eventual heat death of our
universe and if you desire a belief
system that merges poorly written
science fiction with an alien base
volcanic cosmology and multi-thousand
dollar commitment well call Tom Cruise
and even if you still feel an urge to
find meaning in the world spending time
with shows like Rick and Morty and
Bojack horseman and give some insight
into how the philosophical ramifications
of nihilism look in practice neither
type of nihilism is about giving up
completely but rather they both offer
approaches to moving forward in a
largely uncertain world but if you're a
cosmic nihilist and you've got a date
this Valentine's Day maybe wait until
the third or fourth date to bring it up
and as always thanks for watching guys
hey everyone this is not an ad so don't
click off just yet as I mentioned early
in the video the idea for this video
came from a fan email I just want to
take a second to show appreciation for
the fans and to address some of the
questions that we've heard people ask
can you guys do the philosophy of
wisecrack what is what is the point of
what you guys do do you guys have any
political belief stuff like that so I
wanted to take a second to address this
through a fan email that particularly
touched me so this is from Trevor he
says I just wanted to send an earnest
personal note of thanks to wisecrack for
the thought-provoking content in the
wisecrack Edition Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood video I have lived my adult
life without faith of any sort this
video truly put things into perspective
and articulated thoughts and ideas I've
never been able to quite understand
thank you so much for helping me open my
mind a bit more and respect other points
of view and that's kind of one of the
things that makes wisecrack meaningful
to me
it's empathy it's allowing new ideas to
be communicated to people through the
things they love and ultimately the idea
of seeing life through another person's
point of view and respecting other
opinions that's what it's all about for
me so this email really touched me and I
also wanted to say thank you to
everybody who supports us on patreon
thank you to everybody listens to our
podcasts and thank you to everybody
who's always leaving comments we've got
some really smart people putting stuff
in the comments if you want to check out
more videos we've got like 300 of them
so click on the icon next to the channel
name it'll bring you to our channel page
where you can watch some of my favorite
videos philosophy of South Park season
20 I love philosophy of Christopher
Nolan part 1 part 2 is good too but you
know they're all my babies so I have a
soft spot for many of them thank you
guys so much don't forget to subscribe
and send us emails hit us up on Twitter
everything we love hearing from you guys
so thank you so much peace
[Music]